non vi spaventate sono l'insegnante di
stretching della prova cioè la sto
aiutando a prepararsi per la lezione non
fare con la faccia di roma bello a tutti
ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj dai
viaggi siamo tornati sugli alberi
simulator che tra l'altro hanno
aggiornato un'altra volta che mi chiesta
la giornali si propaga ma che poi
cominciamo cominciamo ok ragazzi
nell'episodio di oggi devo fare una cosa
che mi servirà per vivere tramite la mia
vista non ti voglio vedere perfetto
perfetto perfetto l'effetto ci siamo
dexter eccola qui per fare questo stiamo
cercando proprio questa adesso che ho
questa cosa
fase 2 tu non hai visto niente che io
questa cosa e per l'amor di dio non hai
visto niente
che palle che c'è gente ok ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla questa l'appoggio qui dove
di questo bel coltello da rituale che
c'hai bene in questo preciso istante
devi morire a questo che cazzo fai tu
che cosa guardi questo due anni preghi
adesso che abbiamo fatto questa bella
cosa tutti dentro tutti dentro il
cerchio dell'area che cazzo fai non va
detto queste satana che prende possesso
del tuo corpo dentro cerchio
dell'evocazione che devo fare le cose
l'agente ucciso lega entra santana
lasciamelo lascia quello che mi serve
lasciami quest'uomo ecco grazie alle
satana ti sei mio amico
adesso siamo all'ultima parte adesso che
siete tutti qua nel centro seconda parte
del piano è dimenticato questo questo
velo discriminato torino la seconda
parte del piano consiste nel prendere
questa sega circolare e cercare di
smembrare qualsiasi persona si trovi
all'interno di questo cerchio così fatta
la mia vocazione dello furto
aspetto passiamo al prossimo ragazzi vi
devo scortare tutti quanti e mi spiace
quanto faticosa la scuola vero che ha
eroso ragazzi purtroppo andare a scuola
dieci giorni un po è un po difficile ho
capito no no tu adesso preente dentro
qua dentro perfetto no non è che devi
scambiarlo da gamba ecco grazie funziona
funziona fame del potere rosso anch'io
ok basta si muove tutto io sono forte o
squartato tutti qua io va ad ascoltare
le persone rotta [ __ ]
ma chi sei cagliari addosso al mio
cospetto non si caga buffon sta che
lanciando loro distanti
poi non potete cucinare cucino io con le
mie 10 braccia credo di avere più
manualità di mori e manualità l'avete
capita male buongiorno prova perché so
ha detto che sono arrivato in ritardo
prima erano soltanto tre minuti garbato
mi dispiace palme
io sono qua fermo non datemi quando
volete non ammettete se ne di tempo e
preferisco nel caso tu hai notato
qualcosa perché non ero molto più niente
non si sa come adesso servisse tutta ci
ha ripensato spunto creativo non volevo
ucciderla
sono incredibile rischio cambiare anche
i colori vestiti a buongiorno ancora più
brutto deficiente che rimane incastrato
nella sedia e tour non lo aiuti
allora
[Applauso]
io volevo fare una cosa carina non va
dato anche il tempo volevo prima
uccidere lei e poi lui niente mani state
pro carne che guardo si riesce a farmi e
posso fotografare o fotografo le mani
facciamo selphy bellissima questo
fondamento subito su facebook che lo
vede anche la mia mamma allora ragazzi è
stata una giornata abbastanza
impegnativa a scuola oggi quindi direi
che posso concedermi un po di riposo e
andare a casa salve signora non è una
bella giornata vero mi porto questa come
souvenir le dispiace ok perfetto
torniamo a casa
ora sono a casa oddio e notte e la
madonna sono in pigiama un ora gal
apriamo termine di un pigiama sono
emozionato posso andare su facebook
gioco dell'anno
mi chiamo agliano andiamo a dormire
perché non è veramente la cosa più non
senso abbia mai visto prefiggo da
concerto punto di vista è figo rivedo
ancora in bianco e nero in volevo
cambiare visuale mi metti bad times
[Musica]
che cazzo è si considerino dio ma che
cazzo ragazzi la cosa più quanto è
diventato figo questo gioco ragazzi non
fate caso a me mi serve esso solo
facendo allenamento come si torna
indietro
fatemi uscire fatemi uscire ragazzi è
più divertente del flipper che sta
succendo incastrata nell'armadietto zia
non volevo giuro prof
buongiorno posso parlare in un secondo
mi dispiace 7 ieri sono arrivate in
ritardo
adoro questo gioco questo è per la
lezione di matematica
questo e per avermi messo due quando mi
merita un 10 queste per avermi messo in
ritardo questo perché si sdraia questo
perché hai fatto l'occhiolino mio padre
questo perché non vi spaventate sono
l'insegnante di stretching della prof
cioè la sto aiutando a prepararsi per la
lezione non fare con la faccia 0
comunque sia e ai delle scarpe di merda
non volevo dirtelo è perché l'italia
prova un fango e noi ti lascia
incastrata la lavagna quello il tuo
posto per il resto della vita el è
calata la linea
renditi utile e voglia di giocare un po
lo vedo convinto gli fate vedere ragazzi
se lo faccio sempre che cosa succede
veramente una curiosità incredibile
arrivo è zio parte che sei più brutto
della foca beta è
a colori più sì che no non puoi farmi
così non mi pare così non mi fare così
con sempre ti prego iddio devi prendere
anche lui noi non può essere soggiogati
dalla mia potere
[ __ ] allora sai che ti dico toti
mentre lo faccio agli altri miti ed
estrae arrivata la propria tra prof
giorno prof
c'era morto qua tranquillo nella
tragedia chiami la polizia scientifica
puoi anche polare quanto vuoi ma la
polizia non la chiave 6 non lo decido io
e bellissimo al passo di danza più bello
che abbia mai visto ve la vedete che lo
stretching serve comunque fare come
sciolta e svenuta ragazzi non volevo
giuro va beh direi che possiamo
concludere quadra perché stop zio come
ho fatto
ma allora non volevo farlo schiantare mi
dispiace allora ragazzine che possono
includere un episodio degli under
simulator con questa bella vista
involontaria dire che oggi è stata una
giornata produttiva soprattutto per
avere la scuola se non si interpellata
non devi parlare in corso a chiamare da
ragazzi concluso che l'episodio spero
che vi do vi sia piaciuto a caso insieme
958 mi piace e ricordatevi di fare
stretching con i prof prima di
cominciare la lezione perché se no anche
la pagina di facebook e come notizia ne
siano sapersi di scritti di ci vediamo
al posto dei ragazzi